the first wife of the gunman who killed
26 people under Texas Church is speaking
out for the very first time Tessa
Brennaman is her name she was married to
former airman devin Patrick Kelly for 18
months
Kelly was court-martialed back in 2012
for beating Brennaman and for fracturing
the skull of his very young stepson he
was sentenced to 12 months confinement
and received a bad conduct discharge the
Air Force failed to submit his criminal
history to the FBI which would have
barred him from buying guns
Brenneman talked to Inside Edition
correspondent Stephen Fabian about how
she lived in fear during her marriage he
would choke me punch me kick me there
would be times where I'd be on the floor
crawled up and having to protect my
organs because he would be violently
kicking me on my side like I was less of
a person is how I made me feel I
remember I contacted my sister and let
her you know know what happened and
security forces which is the equivalent
of like police for the Air Force he told
me you know if you do this if you told
them I'm gonna kill you and your entire
family so he threatened to kill you in
your whole family yeah did you believe
him I didn't take it lightly and he's
like you know I could just bury you
somewhere here in the desert and nobody
would ever find you Inside Edition
anchor Deborah Norville joins us at the
table to discuss good morning good
morning good to have you back so she was
19 when she got married - how old is she
now she is in her mid-twenties mid-20s
it sounds terrifying the whole time what
did she think when she heard that he was
a gunman behind the shoes she found out
from social media when she heard about
the shooting she had no idea and then
when she heard it was Devin she she said
she her vision got blurry she got
shortness of breath she almost had like
a vertigo she ran to her neighbor's
house she just had to be with someone
she was so stunned by it all but I think
she would probably say not really
surprised when you think long and hard
about it but that initial initial
incident was oh my goodness yeah leave
it describing that history of violence
yes the gunman's first wife also told
you guys about a frightening argument
over a speeding ticket let's listen yeah
and he had a gun in his holster right
here
and he took that gun out and he put it
to my template and he told me do you
want to die do you want to die and I
knew better not to cry because if I
cried he was the type of person that
would beat me until I would stop crying
while he's doing this I'm like okay
Devin it's okay you don't have to be
upset you're gonna regret doing this and
finally got him to stop holding it to my
head and then he put it to his head and
he started crying and he was like this
is all my fault it's all my fault and
I'm like what are you talking about
what's all your fault
and he was like you know I'm the one who
hurt your son and I was like so angry
when he told me that she reported her
husband yes police does she think that
the authorities did enough she's furious
it's interesting that argument that she
described pulling the gun was over a
speeding ticket if you do a background
check that speeding ticket and running a
stop sign is all you will find on Devin
Kelley however if you look at his
court-martial papers it goes into great
detail about the abuse of the child the
abuse of Tessa she's furious with the
Air Force she says he should have gotten
a longer sentence at the time he was
court-martialed the Air Force Secretary
has apologized that the records were not
updated as they should have been this
probably could have been prevented she
reported she divorced him for 2012
correct yeah and when did she hear from
him last
well it's interesting she was in a store
and she saw Devin Kelly's current wife
they didn't speak they simply saw one
another he then reached out to her and
said if you interact with us again you
will live to regret it
consider this your only an ultimate
warning and this was in March of this
year yeah if you interact with us again
just some great pastor she's literally
fast in the store they did not exchange
words they didn't even exchange glances
they just noticed each other you report
that no she did not
so why is she speaking now do you think
several she's speaking out because when
you hear her story tonight on Inside
Edition you're gonna hear a litany of
abuse of her of the child she says other
women are in this situation she said
someone will hear this story and they
will see themselves and they want them
to reach out and she wants them to reach
out and get help Easter's all the
authorities get in a safe place
get out chose her son no he's better he
is fully recovered he has no less
impacts from the abuse you've suffered
alright Deborah Norville thank you very
much thank you